all right i knew nothing about this
movie and then at cinemacon there's this
trailer for this movie called beast and
i was like
idris elba meets the ghost in the
darkness but idris elba has to save his
family and protect them from the lion
like that's
i'm in and then
[Music]
so b stars idris elba he's a widower
father of two and he and his two girls
go to this village in africa
where his wife was from he has a friend
there played by charlotte o'copely they
go on a safari they want to see some
animals now there's this pissed off lion
out there who's hunting them and trying
to kill them and then pretty quickly
after that the movie just started
unraveling and falling apart like i said
though the premise at the beginning just
reminded me of idris elba meets ghost in
the darkness i can totally see why a
studio green lit this you kidding me
they were probably like john connor
going to the galleria easy money
right let's get this done let's make
some cash idris elba was great in the
movie idris elba is always great though
you can put idris elba in the biggest
piece of [ __ ] on earth and he's still
great in it the guy gives 150
100 of the time but really it's the jeep
crashes the jeep won't start now the
lion's trying to get into the jeep you
can only do that so many times you only
have to lie and try to get at them so
many times before it starts to feel
redundant so you can tell they were just
trying to make scenarios up including
but not limited to dumb decision making
made by poorly written idiotic
characters the older daughter in here at
a point it's
look idiotic decision making
and characters being obnoxious it's just
those are little nitpicks but you do it
enough it starts to stack up to the
point where you're like all right the
characters are now compromising my
enjoyment of the movie though not the
only reason a couple of examples of
whether it was idris elba telling them
like okay stay in this jeep i'm gonna go
get him because the friend was wounded i
will be back and she was like you'll be
back like you said mom wasn't gonna die
and she did i was like
what a lion is trying to kill and eat us
but you want to hash this [ __ ] out now
that's
that's okay will that be the only eye
rolling moment for me no because at a
point no one had eyes on this line no
one knew where this line was only that
the lion was out there hunting them and
she just gets out of the vehicle and
just runs off into the wilderness like i
gotta find him i will say in terms of
cinematography
multiple scenes where they did that one
shot technique where it didn't look like
there were any cuts in the camera it was
just one shot it was impressive before
the movie even started falling apart in
the end the promise that this movie had
versus what it delivered is just
astronomically disappointing for me this
could have been an interesting and
unique low-budget low-key survival film
let's say you just have idris elba on
the safari the jeep crashes it's broken
down this lion's trying to kill him and
that's the movie it'll be low budget
takes place in one location but far more
interesting kind of like that blake
lively shark movie i enjoyed that
surprisingly i thought i was gonna hate
it but i actually liked it could have
been like that with idris elba and a
lion but instead you can tell they were
like well we can't have them stay in the
jeep the entire time we can't make that
interesting because that is difficult to
do but it can be done they're like all
right we need to get them moving how do
we do that all right well we'll just
have the characters be idiots
essentially just throwing the characters
under the bus for the sake of momentum
but that's not momentum at all that's
the illusion of momentum you don't have
momentum what you have is an auditorium
full of moviegoers who are now rooting
for the lion a couple of moments of
tension i'm not going to say it's not in
here there are a couple of moments i was
like oh man don't breathe you don't want
the lion to find you but a couple of
good moments of tension don't make up
for the fact that this movie felt like
it was
movie of the week you know you remember
movie of the week we've moved past this
our whole generation doesn't know what
movie of the week is yeah you know
before streaming services back in prime
time television days those movies that
weren't theatrical they were made for
television this movie kind of feels like
one of those i will say the movie was 90
minutes and i do appreciate that any
longer i would have hated this movie but
as it stands as a movie i'm just not
going to remember not in t minus one day
yep already forgot all right so beast
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's your favorite
thriller involving the wilderness and or
carnivores in which people are trying to
survive pretty vague i guess jurassic
park is going to be the winner on that
one
that's not jurassic park whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you